of cookie being a haircut to someone
even in general if something that makes
you fulfilling better image of yourself
we really wanted to give the chance to
some professional hairdresser who are
migrants to feed father the team we want
to leave them something and not just
have in Haryana been a good action noise
about them the end of the day we
attacked the head without even seven and
we didn't even had enough tools so I was
cutting the back to do machine the
cheaper they were using my season and we
were talking and it was all or like that
and you could see the eyes expression of
some of our new friends that was amazing
you